this is the theme the danger this is the
things is the D this malad hamdulillah
assalamualaikum which is greeting a
peace peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the Dean show my
guest today we're honored to have dr.
Mohammad Matt do you can go to the Dean
show com he is the advisor academic
advisor for the American Open University
and the list goes on the program's go by
fast so you can go to the website to
read a little bit more about him we're
going to be because we've been getting
some requests many we're going to be
talking about the sisters and sonam the
woman in Islam the rights of women in
Islam today there's some confusion women
feel like they really have had their
women's movement and that some rights
have been achieved but Islam did this
1400 years ago that's what we're going
to be talking about today when we come
back here on the Dean so we'll see you
in a few
this is the team the teacher mrs. the
things is the theme
the video this is the thing is the theme
this is the angel Salaam alaikum alaikum
assalaam what I'm not lying when I got
them please be unto you and to you as
well you back again yeah here in the
Dean show hunger in there and Charlotte
going to keep having you back in
chandler people are getting the benefit
from your knowledge each other and today
we're going to pick your brain some more
you hear one of the things that some
people will associate with Islam is the
subjugation of women that we put the
woman down but it's interesting more
women are coming to Islam than men so
let's clear up this misconception by
educating people by letting people know
what is the true status of women in
Islam zack long island for this yeah
first of all it's it's true what you've
said that according to the statistics we
know that more women come to Islam than
men and this is quite obvious and the
reason for that and whenever you ask any
woman who became a muslimah if she would
tell you that I feel safe and protected
in this religion and I feel abused and
subjected to any problem whenever I was
before Islam and because you know that
yeah a lot of people would abuse women
and most of the crimes because the
natural weaknesses of women and men they
try to use their physical strength to
force women to do things and that's why
they found that Islam is the religion
and the ideology and the way of life
that gives full protection to Islam to
women and and if we go back to Islam and
I would like to go back even before
Islam people talk about women usually
that were badly treated by the
arabs before Islam and I think this this
is not true i will tell you three or
four examples yeah yeah of course they
are not they were not treated as good as
they had been treated by Islam but even
I would talk about even the time of j
healey women were treated at that time
much better than nowadays let me give
you an example for example the financial
independence with many examples in the
history of the earth's before the time
of the prophet muhammad sallallahu that
women had this financial independence
they have full control and they're
probably on their properties they have
full control on the people who work
beneath them they had a word to say and
protect for example women were allowed
to protect men if somebody comes from
another tribe resorting to this stripe
and he would say that i would take this
man or that woman a protector for me the
society would acknowledge that if the
person is the man or the woman would say
that I will protect X so he is protected
she got this power even before Islam and
I wonder what what happens in the world
nowadays if you compare this with what's
going on in the world you will find that
really this was an amazing thing another
thing that look at Khadijah for example
right she was totally free full she had
full control on her money and big names
at her time wanted to marry her and she
refused she had the full word it full
word in the full sense of the where and
the meaning of the word she was not
needing her father or her mother or
somebody else to talk on her behalf she
was the one to decide I accept this
manner except this man and she's the one
who hired prophet mohamed salah salem
before he was a prophet he hired him to
work for her yeah and this could try to
imagine that the freedom she had she is
the one who would select her employees
and reject this and reject this she's
the one who decides to marry this man or
this man she's full freedom before them
and even
even we know that some herbs very few
Arabs used to kill the daughters before
before Islam when they were alive to
bury them alive which is such a savage
thing no doubt it was like their form of
abortion at or worse episode this is
much worse it's much worse I don't look
they really look down it's yeah it's
very very desert listen at all does not
go with a human nature yeah but when you
look into that matter and you explore it
you will find that the herbs who did
that which were few in numbers they used
to do this out of love for Dell
fulfilled their daughters and their
women the reason is that at that time
this was a tribal society this is this
tribe is strong enough to attack this
stripe and would kill them in and would
take the women right and they would
enslave them and they would yes abuse
them and he would do many bad things
work and the Earth's they had the honor
and they had the integrity to refuse
such things to the degree that they
prefer to kill their daughter rather
than to leave their daughter to become
captives for those attackers from other
tribes even that they had a point which
reflects that this is not out of
disrespect or dislike of women rather it
was out of love for them they wanted to
protect them so when they were attacked
so the the women would not be enslaved
by the other times yeah even that issue
I don't want to go even much details in
that but i would love to tell you that
even the prostitutes at that time they
had more freedom than free women
nowadays let me just give you a
minister's ever yet okay one example is
that women years 20 practiced in
prostitution before the Islam would make
a tent and would put a flag red flag so
everybody would know that this is a
house of prostitution so the people
would come to this house let me assume
that there is a house
of a prostitute that had been visited by
5 or 6 or 7 10 min right and then after
some time the woman the prostitute
became pregnant yeah she had the power
that she would say this man you know
that at that time there was no DNA yeah
she would select this man or that man is
it you are the father of my child and he
has to accept because the society
accepted this yeah in other words she
had the power to say that this is the
father of my son and the whole society
the whole community would acknowledge
this so powerful if the woman is weak
nobody would give her this right but she
had this right even before his lap I'm
not saying that this is something good
of course yeah but I'm trying to show
you that the picture or the whole
portrait that was given to humanity
about how the women were treated before
Islam was not a true picture yeah was
that was just a superficial picture but
even though Islam came and gave women
much much more rights than what they had
before is that's what we're going to get
into God willing next when we come back
after the break we write back I don't
say to people i used to be a question I
still carry the values and principles of
loving Jesus Christ perhaps you may be
more than even comes as Christians so I
think I got the best out of Christianity
by becoming Muslim
so many other things that you can enjoy
without drinking a sip of alcohol this
is the same thing it's not an obstacle
it's not something to cause people to
get completely desperate and start
talking living their life snow it should
be a motivation it's only one life that
you're going to be living so you better
do it for a las China matata
I am not afraid to stay alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if allies by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone if Eliza I
am Not Afraid
welcome back to the Dean show we're
talking to
in Islam and we talked about with dr.
mundo some of the status a woman before
what Islam and now we are going to
continue on talking about Islam when now
the people were exposed to this way of
life the way of life of all the
messengers of submitting to the one who
created you when the guidance came to
the people talk about this how this
raised the woman up in status yeah when
his lab came and give women more rights
that they had before yes so some of the
practices were accepted by Islam and
some of course were rejected for example
women were given of course they still
continue to have their financial freedom
and this is something very interesting
that when a rich woman in Islam married
marries a man or his poor or rich she
doesn't cost him anything in other words
she doesn't pay anything from her pocket
he is the one who is fully in a charge
of that her money is for her it's not
used by him but he is the one who is
supposed to sponsor air and to spend his
money or her and to prepare everything
that she needs for the house yeah so she
keeps her money and she uses her money
in other words in his money in other
words so he's truly the sugar daddy as
they say absolutely and she's been an
absolutely becomes the sugar dad but at
the same time he's giving her all her
rights all her bride is using and
dumping her like what's going on today a
sugar daddies will buy you a little bit
of a diamond here yes but then after
he's had his thrills okay I'm gonna go
now this is not the case of sugar daddy
feel had some rights now and this is
hamdullah when a woman marries a person
with this contract type of could let me
tell you something about the contract as
people said we know that polygamy is
allowed in Islam which is for obvious
logical reason that anybody can see I
will talk about this later but even a
person who has this right to have three
or four wives still
it is the right of the wife if somebody
proposes to her and wants to marry her
it is the right of the wife to reject
that to say in the contract when my
conditions in the contract is that you
do not marry another woman if he signed
this contract so he is Islamically
obliged to fulfill the terms of the
contract so she still has the right to
do and again one of the misconceptions
here to add to this one of the
misconceptions people think that women
in Islam marry without their consent in
fact this is totally absolutely
incorrect you can't just take the woman
say it's absolutely over to this guy and
saying you're going to marry him she
doesn't have any say she does have a say
to the degree that if this happens this
is not considered marriage it's rather
it is considered some sort of adultery
yeah a woman has to say her word to
agree on the person and she should never
be force it and I want people to
differentiate between the practices of
some people and what is the teachings of
Islam they call it like arranged
marriages arranged marriage even if it
is arranged marriage however it is it
she has to have the concepts alertly
it's different with absolutely arranged
we mean like okay your father mother
they might know a family that they have
a good son or good daughter so they're
trying to meet instead of going out and
just freestyle go meet anybody here
there and you know without the parents
being involved what's prevalent today
family's always involved that's the
range of the talent not only that the
involvement of the parent or the brother
or the uncle it's for the benefit of her
because they supported they are
consultant for her here are they
explained things for her because she may
not know the person quite well they are
the informants that they get some
information about this person and we
tell her the picture and leave her to
decide help her to take to make the
decision like if you have your child is
trying to join I University and he is
reluctant which specialty he would join
you would try to guide him
and this may take you lead with lead you
to do this and this and that's why they
have these orientation courses in the
universities to guarantee that the
students before the selection he or she
knows what he or she is doing so those
are considered consultants you can say
that or experts on the matter who give
her advice to help her take the right
decision oh this is the most important
thing marriage you should be consulting
with your family absolutely that's what
is absolute comment in any area of the
world when you take a decision by
yourself without concerti without
consulting the people who have the
expertise definitely your decision would
not be as right as when you have a lot
of concerns that just makes good sense
because of what you've seen a lot of the
youth do today is they just go out there
on their own and they exclude their
family they're not right that's not
right at all be they deprived themselves
from these long experiences that they
have yeah and I think any wise what
leader as you see that all the leaders
of the world has all these cabinets and
cold symptoms around them to help them
take the right make the right decision
this is exactly the situation a woman
are not only a woman but a man as well
he needs to be consulted so that's why
he asks his parents he asks his friends
it asks his uncle's to get information
the right information and based on this
information he or she would take the
decision many people from the outside
even some Muslims will have a hard time
because maybe the environment were in
but talk about the wisdom and not it
being something that's forced upon a
woman but she makes a decision or so
that you know what she's going to
dressed how the crater wants her to
dress that modest away so let's talk
about this hijab step step from the
outside someone says why is she covering
like this why should just show it all
that's true freedom that's not true
freedom is it let's talk about the
wisdom behind the honesty of the
muscleman it's something very obvious to
any one in the world so something that
everybody practices a Muslim or
non-prime
non-muslim when you have something
precious when you have something
valuable you want to protect it
absolutely you want to keep it in a
place that cannot be affected by others
cannot be stolen cannot be abused you
know anything that you own that's
valuable you don't just throw it in the
street like that how you try to keep it
and you try to protect it this is
exactly what Islam gives to them Islam
loves the woman and knows that she's so
precious so valuable that needs to be
protected because of the natural beauty
that Allah span org Allah and out to
women right it's a more Beauty than
given to women that men which is
everybody can see that right therefore
they need more protection and the way to
be protected a las panatela legislated
that when they come out they come out
covering themselves so their beauty is
not shown to others because once it is
shown they become subject to any type of
rape or any type of attack and you can
see this let's assume that five women
are working in the streets three or four
of them are half-naked or quarterly
naked or some parts of their body are
Shawn and one of them is fully covered
and if we find other people men
especially watching and observing them
definitely they will be following the
ones who are more naked in their bodies
and they would not do that to the other
woman why because her beauty is covered
so when we say the beauty is covered to
find us a little bit elaborate on it so
this is you know that is a different
light skin like your definition make it
my job yeah of course so no tight things
that saw her were there are all the
opposite end until we start to up some
elevate and turn to going you know that
needs to be covered yes and the man
needs to lower his game that because of
the beauty of women uh-huh Allah Allah
Allah commanded min first to lower the
gay so it's a man of course women are
Oscar too
as women are more beautiful than men in
general that that's why Allah smart
aleck commanded men first to lower their
gaze and then he command this we gather
together they are perfect lower case
because once you open your eyes right
you cannot stop the effects that will
happen to your brain and to your heart
yeah so that's why this is the snow
that's why you see the whole system
pieces together to complete the puzzle
if we had more of this yeah like we see
today that this sex industry the
pornography we're living in the real
world will it is some a billion-dollar
inocula is feeding off the desire of men
absolutely so this is LOM preserves the
women and protects her through this head
job isn't it absolutely go to any book
shop and find magazines if you find
twenty magazines at least you'll find 19
if not 20 magazines out of 20 exposing
exploiting the women exploiting women
that's not true freedom and this is one
of the reasons why women become muslims
and this statistic was very clear in
germany when a lot of German woman said
that we don't want to be treated as sex
objects absolutely as objects can I say
that sex object that's what they're
being treated at of course yeah I said
this is the truth uh-huh Islam gives
much respect to that yeah yes of course
Islam what does not object to sex in the
legal way that Allah spinal so now in
the house she can take it all absolutely
absolute her husband absolutely it's on
in in fact amazingly yeah you would find
how Islam encouraged this the prophet
salallahu salem mentioned an amazing
hadith that would encourage a person yes
to to have this strong intimacy with his
wife and he they asked him he said that
you will be rewarded by allah if you do
that and they were shocked and they this
raises the question in them and they
asked the professor la sala do we get
our we rewarded when we practice that
intimacy with our wives he said yes
because if you practice it in an illegal
way you are punished by Almighty Allah
so if you practice it in a legal way you
will be rewarded by a
with that let's take a break let's stick
and we'll be right back online do not
feel a woman do not kill a child do not
you know going to different religious
life Buddhism Hinduism forms of
Christianity I even rather to people
from the Nation of Islam feeling very
mad you will not feel an animal you will
not cut a tree down do not remove the
water do not burn their homes
welcome back to the Dean show we are
here talking about the true studies the
upliftment of something that is more
precious than diamonds and money and
cars is a woman we love the women and we
want them to truly get their rights and
how can you get their rights through the
one who created them the one who knows
them the Creator that happens an earthen
we're here with dr. men do and we want
to continue talking about we left off
where you said now that even that when
one is having intimate relations with
his wife he's getting rewarded you'd be
worried by Almighty love with that
that's amazing what the amazing this is
why because this is one way to protect
the family to protect a woman to protect
the husband himself from falling into
sins that let's uh let's talk about this
there is some confusion also we
primarily we want to reach out to the
non-muslims and now they got to see that
there's no forced marriages in Islam
absolutely there's so much to cover we
just given him a taste we talked about
that the woman through this job is
protected she's liberated she's not
subjugated but for some Muslims some
some women some people will think that
you know what the hijab is not an
obligatory thing is it is it a consensus
among all the scholars and from today
and from the past that this is something
that is obligatory on every Muslim woman
I wouldn't say it among the scholars
yeah I would say it's direct command
from Almighty Allah in the Quran Shelia
driba be homo rahim allah gob him they
should make their cover hide their head
rather head scarves and and the one of
their bosoms their chests clear clear
cut command and the people who try to
twist things and to play with things
they would say that the world itself is
not used of course yes when you say that
the word alcohol is not used in the
quran
I would say yes but the word wine is
used you understand what I'm saying so
that the where the people try to deceive
others by using these words playing with
words and people are deceived Oh show me
one single word in in the Quran like
that but of course there are many other
words mirror there's something called
synonyms in any language and the way you
express it for example when you say that
it's not necessary that I say this is
haram but I say that this is not allowed
in Islam same thing you don't do that
it's which means it's prohibited it's
not all the time I say that it's
prohibited said that you're not allowed
to do that yes we have a science of this
hadith the sayings of the last semester
last farmers problem hon peace be upon
him that the Quran goes he's the teacher
of the Quran he's the walk-ups
instructional is there a situation where
a woman came and he had turned away and
he had instructed that the only thing
that should be shown are the face and
the hands yes and nothing transparent
elaborate on this yes there's of course
when when they say that the Companions
say described this when this verse came
that we have seen the women at that time
yes we're covering everything as if they
are they were crow yeah yeah so they
were describing this so what the
difference among the scholars is not in
there's a jab or not there's a jab the
difference is that the form of the hi
jab and the shape of the idea hopefully
that's yes there's some scholars and
this is the majority of scholars that
they say that women should cover
everything and some scholars would say
that they are allowed to cover their
whole bodies except the face and the
hands however if a woman feels that she
is beautiful as most women she's
supposed to cover her face again because
this is a protection for the whole
society here if you look at someone
because this might be added some people
but the best of women that even let's
say the non-muslims would look at they
look at what we have we don't know what
Mary's mother's look like but what they
paint the picture you'll see her that's
any job the best of the best of the
Christian woman the nuns not see this is
a mess hall
cheb this yeah they are covering
everything except their friends yeah and
this is a proof a proof in itself that
this hedge app was not only an
obligation on the Muslim it was an
obligation on the non-muslims as well
and the previous theory was and this is
the proof by the Christians themselves
yeah by the nuns themselves who are the
closest one to follow the traditions of
Jesus peace be upon him tell us now for
the Muslim woman who is afraid because
she has Muslim parents but her Muslim
parents will kick her out of the house
if she wears hijab or the Muslim parents
he's a Muslim parent you have these
situations going on where they're giving
their daughters because they're scared
that now this is going to bring harm to
them that now they're going to be
exposed and they're going to be known as
Muslims and because of you know certain
circumstances absolute this might bring
hardships and I said we don't this was
for that time like it kind of expired or
so yeah what do we have these are the
phobic fears that happened perhaps after
some incidents that happened in 2001 or
so but it happens like this but again we
want to tell this woman who wears her
job and she's afraid of her she's not
wearing hijab we want you worried yeah
we want her and I said that in the
beginning of the previous episode when I
talked about the key to paradise I said
that when you know a las palette Allah
and you love him you would never want to
disobey him because he got the utmost
love from you the priority love is given
to Allah then is given to someone else
after that whether it's the parent or to
the spouse or the chart to the child but
the main love is for Almighty Allah and
again we said that this love to be
translated by submission should be
translated so one sign of submission to
Almighty Allah from women is wearing the
hijab because a las panel allah
commanded men to do things that men can
do and vice versa so he puts anything on
anyone
it's not in their ability to do
absolutely this is again comes back to
what we said that last part I holla when
he commands somebody to do something
Allah knows that it is within his
capacity and within his ability so it is
within the capacitance is the part of
the test are you going to pass or fail
absolutely it's a test yeah she going to
pass the test or not is she going to
please Allah more or to please her
parents is she going to please Allah or
the society is she going to please Allah
or her husband she going to please Allah
or her employer as she has to make the
balance any Muslim he would listen to
these questions immediately the answer
is none to any Muslim yeah i'm going to
please allah say regardless of what site
may god almighty allah reward you for
being with us well yeah thank you honey
come on boy and thank you for being with
us on another episode of the Dean show
we just gave you a small taste you can
go into our library read more about the
status of women in Islam which simpson
simply means peace acquired by
submitting to the will of the one who
created you and your Creator knows
what's best so he's given you some
things that he knows you can do that he
knows that you can strive in his way and
he will make it easy for you you just
have to have the vision the picture
painted that this life will end and the
angel of death will come to a structure
so are you going to be prepared when
everyone is gone and just you and the
grave and you hear those footsteps
walking away and now it's too late I
should have I could have I should have
did that and this and the other but it's
too late now don't let that moment come
pray to the one who created you to make
it easy and he will and then strive to
submit and be in line with what
everything that he's told you to do
because he loves you the most so love
him back by being obedient we'll see you
next time on a Dean show us all I'm
alaikum peace be unto you